- Y'all look so rock and roll right now.
- Thank you.
- Modern rock and roll.
I'm into it.
- We're like the Powerpuff Girls.
Yeah, we've been trying to coordinate,
but it hasn't really worked.
(guests laughing)
- [Kelly] No, it's great!
- Obviously the message hasn't...
- So Riley, so I've heard you,
I've heard you truly dream
about making a certain kind of movie.
What is it?
I think it's a kind of movie
I don't watch cuz I'm scared.
- It's, oh, you mean
when, when I was little?
- You wanna make horror films?
- I made lots of horror films.
I made, they're finished.
- Okay. At what age?
At what age were you making horror films?
- Well, I think I discovered
that ketchup could be blood
and then I kind of ran with
it for about three years.
And, um...
- You were a fun kid.
- Yeah.
- You're like my boy Remy.
That's amazing.
I love it. Would you still do horror?
- I would, I've done, you know, I've done
like horror thriller,
kind of psychological.
- Thriller psychological I can do.
- You can do. Yeah.
I don't know, like horror.
I get, I get very scared, so.
- I have to be completely
honest with people
on my couch when they say
they're in a horror film.
And I'm gonna be like
- You're never gonna watch it.
- I will never watch your film
(all laughing)
- Because I will have nightmares.
I literally am so affected by it.
Like I can take like
thriller, like, you know.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Anything like that.
- Like Sixth Sense.
- Yes.
- [Riley] You can handle that.
- Yeah. I can be like,
"Oh my god, he was dead the whole time."
Sorry, spoiler alert.
But like I, but it's your fault
if you haven't seen it yet.
But no, I can't do like,
- Like slasher, gory.
- [Kelly] Nah. I'm out.
- No ketchup blood.
- So wait, so did, did
you ever do anything like
make movies when y'all were little?
Did you do horror with
ketchup or anything else?
- I would film, actually, I
would always have a VHS camera
and kind of ask inappropriate
questions to the,
to the adults.
- You would film like documentaries.
- Yeah, I was doing like
very much documentaries.
- You were like doing Spinal Tap.
- Yeah. Exactly.
- Isn't your mom here?
Your mom could tell us
what you were doing.
- Oh my God. Yeah.
She is, my mom is here.
My mom's never been to LA before
and she just decided to
come this week and now she
- Wait is your mama here?
- And she was like, if you
call me out, I'll kill you.
- Oh, she's shaking her head.
- I called her out, I called her out.
- Oh mama, you're wearing
my favorite color.
I love green.
This is her first trip?
- First trip.
- That's so fun.
- I've been, I've been coming
to LA for like 10 years
or something and they've
never made it out.
- [Kelly] Oh wow.
- And so, and so she just
decided to come this week and
and be part of this whole
experience for a week.
- You should do some
of the tourist things,
the beach. All that stuff.
- Yeah. Oh yeah.
We're gonna go to the beach tomorrow.
- Yeah. That's so fun.
I love that.
Alright, Camila, did you ever do anything
when you were a kid?
Like make,
- Did I do anything when I was a kid?
- Make movies?
Make movies?
- I am, I am, I have lost my laptop
that had my photo booth on it
in my early teenage years.
I don't know where it is.
- At least it's Photo
Booth and not TikTok.
- Well, well I don't know
what's on there for like
a five year period of my life
and I've lost it, but I just
I just imagine like, I
just remember being like,
I was like a sad, sad girl.
Like, like a Lana Del Rey.
No, no, I was, I would
put it on, I'd do like
I would do like sad music videos
like looking out like the
window and it was raining.
- So dramatic.
- I did that.
- Like listening to Lana Del Rey
and being like, "Yeah, my
life is sweet like cinnamon"
and just like, I just had like
simpy, emotional YouTube,
uh, Photo Booth videos.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I don't know
where they are today, so
- I did that to Tattoo,
but I was older than you.
- Oh yeah.
- Oh my god. I remember Photo Booth.
- There was Lana Del Rey,
there was like a lot of like
we were just in our feelings
and as like a 13 year old gal.
- Puberty.
Hits hard.
Yeah, it was like
- Oh yeah.
She was in like peak,
Lana Del Rey was peaking
- Being 13 and La Del Rey coming out and
- She was my everything,
I mean, we were just
we were just crying.
- I think this was my, this
was my Alanis Morissette
That was my, that was, yeah.
And I was like, wait, women can say this?
I was like, people in the
South aren't allowed to
say this if you're a girl. Love her.
So who were some of your
favorite artists from the
seventies?
- It's really hard to
pick one artist, you know?
I love Joni Mitchell.
- Oh, because you have taste.
(all laughing)
- I love the Bee Gees.
(all agreeing)
- All the harmonies.
- Oh my gosh, should we try them now?
- We would just, I was just,
listening to the Bee Gees
and Barbara Streisand.
- [Kelly] Love.
- And, and I listened
to some Roberta Flack.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Elton John came out in the seventies.
- Yeah. Love.
- I mean there's so much.
What about you?
- That's a great playlist.
- I was, Mamas and the Papas gal.
- [Kelly] Okay. Love it.
- I just, I just felt
like for my character
it was like aligned with
- They totally tracked.
- Yeah. And then they ended
up using a lot of the music
that I had on my playlist for my character
and that was like, like Carole King.
In the first episode.
You have that amazing
scene coming out of the,
why are you looking at me like that?
- I love you.
I just think you're the cutest.
- She, it looked like you were like,
am I supposed to say this?
- I know. I was like am I spoiling
that you come out of a room
listening to Carole King?
- I don't think that's
gonna be like a spoiler.
- The three of us together are a disaster.
We just, we can't
- You had your sad song as well.
That was a Mamas and Papa song.
- Yeah, it was Dream a Little Dream of Me.
Well cuz my character
cries so much in the show.
- Don't spoil it.
- No, I know, but
- You're like, telling the whole show.
- Billy and Daisy are together.
I'm here. No.
That's all I'll say.
- That's one of the greatest songs ever.
I love that song.
- I agree.
- So can you, can you talk
about who you each play in the show?
We'll start with you Camila
since you're talking down there.
- Okay. Well I'm Camila and I play Camila
And I play the wife of Billy Dunn.
But not only that
she's also kind of the person
who gets the band together.
I mean, she brings Karen,
Suki's character, into the band.
She kind of follows her love to California
to Los Angeles in 1968 or 69 to pursue
pursue music and pursue
her dream of photography.
And then she's a mother and she kind of
I think the audience grows
up with Camila Dunn, you know
she's 17 and then she's
in her late 40s all
within the first season of the show.
So there's a big coming of age story
for, for my character.
- Okay. Well, Suki, who's
your character though?
Who are you playing?
- I play Karen Sirko, who
is the keyboardist in the
in the band and she
- [Camila] There she is.
- [Suki] Oh, there she is.
- I love that.
- I've got one hand on the, on the key
so they're like, that's resting key.
That's not meant, that's not
how I play it in the show.
(all laughing)
But I, yeah, I'm, I'm
the first, I'm the first
I'm the first girl to join
the band before, before Daisy.
And yeah, I joined the
band when they're The Six.
They have a couple of
different iterations,
but yeah, I'm the
I'm the keyboardist of
Daisy Jones and The Six.
- Awesome. How about you Riley?
- I play Daisy Jones.
(audience cheering)
- That's an intense scene that we showed.
- Yeah, I wanted to see it.
I couldn't see it.
- Oh, I did. Rubbing it in.
- It's the jail scene.
- It is, it's the jail scene.
It's so, it's sad.
It sounds really sad.
- It is. That was a really hard
- You were saying you were from Mars
and you didn't have family.
- It was a really sad scene.
- It was a really like sweet
moment we got to have together.
- Yeah.
Seeing you all sad behind the bars.
I was...
(all laughing)
- But she came, she comes to get me.
- Yes.
- And yeah, I play
I play a young songwriter
who kind of discovers that she wants to
be a singer and a performer.
And ultimately joins the band with the
with these guys and, and girl
The Six and we become
Daisy Jones and The Six.
- I love that.
Okay, well Suki and Riley, is it true
that you both went to band camp?
- Oh, we sure did.
(all laughing)
- So what, what was, Band Camp like?
- It was long.
- You sounded like you enjoyed it.
- Yeah. Oh my gosh.
We did, we really enjoyed
it, but it was, you know
we worked really hard.
- Yeah.
- A lot of us had never
done the things we were
doing on this show.
I had never sang, I'd never played guitar.
Suki hadn't played, you
hadn't played the keys.
You know, the other band
members had either never
played their instruments
or they hadn't in a while.
We spent a lot of time
in that room together.
- Do you do it now?
Like obviously you do, but like
do you play now outside of it?
Because now, I don't know
I imagine when you learn
something as an actor
like I, anything you learn, I've talked
to someone that learned how
they had to learn how to swim
to like, for their role or whatever.
Like, do you keep that up?
- So I, I definitely like feel
more confident singing now.
So I'll, like if my
husband sings for example,
I'll sing with him.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- More than I would have before.
The songs I know are
just Daisy Jones songs.
- So I am amazing at those.
- So like I can play those.
- She's being humble.
She's got like one of the
better voices I've ever heard.
She belts in this show.
She's really.
- Also, by the way
(overlapping chatter)
- First of all, we're
with like Kelly Clarkson
This is so, we cannot talk about singing.
- No, I love it!
I love, this is where you talk about it.
I'm a singer. I love it.
- And, well obviously we
know Suki is a rockstar
but in this show Riley has got,
I mean her voice, it's very
it really does remind me
of like Stevie Nicks and
and it has a Janis Joplin,
- [Kelly] Oh my God. That's cool.
- Joni Mitchell vibe.
- That is way overselling it.
- I think.
- You know what though,
when you send those three
singers, you can kind of get
a texture tone in your mind.
So I know that you, you all love music.
You're, you actually tour,
you've released music
you do this in general.
- Yeah.
- This is before the film.
- She's the real, real rockstar.
- She's like living like
she's acting cool right now
but she's like living
a real rockstar life.
Like right now.
Like she was on tour last Friday.
- I know, I just heard your single.
(overlapping chatter)
- Was this inspired by
being a part of this
but it feels like you've
always kind of done this?
- Yeah. So have I have been
writing music and putting out
for a long time.
Yeah. Actually I think, I think
when I started playing Karen
and then we were at Sound
City Studios and we were
making all this music and
I think I got it kind of
I kind of...
- [Kelly] Inspired.
- Yeah. I kind of, I kind
of realized that I had to,
I was it was now to, you
know, make the record
and then we, we stopped for the pandemic.
So, and I guess like being
around all these, you know
empowered, confident women,
I was like, it's time to
make the record that I wanna make.
And I didn't really realize
that by the time we put
out the show I would've done
like 70 shows and 2 tours
and it's like very much been happening.
Which is kind of crazy.
- It's kind of cool that it's coinciding
and you're playing this
character that's doing it
and then the sets have
to be incredible, right?
They like, transport you
like back to that time.
That has to be inspiring as a musician.
- Yeah. Oh my goodness.
I mean we, I wasn't in this
scene, which I was very
jealous about, but we
but you guys got to,
we shut down Sunset and
- Which is like the first time
in 30 years they had shut it
down for a production,
like a really big portion
of Sunset Boulevard
where the Whiskey a Go-Go
and the Troubadour are,
we shut it down and took
over the street and put old cars
and kind of resurfaced the
outside of those old music clubs.
- And performed in all
those venues as Daisy Jones.
- Yeah. And like kind of
seeing it how it was back
then. That was probably cool.
- Yeah, it was amazing.
I mean, they did such a beautiful job.
I think that was one of the most
sort of fun things about the
show is the world building
and getting to be transported
back to the seventies.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
That's the great thing about art.
- A hundred percent.
- [Kelly] I love that.